one out of two for kawhi
he comes away with a steal the gift of
grab elevates and punches it in for the
right hand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no way you can play with the
basketball in front of a wide letter you
just
just can't do it
and then you bring paul george back
maybe late first quarter
or early second quarter and let him
continue to go to work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
flippers match their largest lead of the
game that they established back in the
first quarter of six
leonard leather larceny the defense in
his rear view and he flushes it
in love from above from kawhi leonard
and the clippers lead by eight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
brings the clippers to within four
timeouts san antonio
one out of two for kawhi
he comes away with a steal the gift of
grab elevates and punches it in for the
right hand did you see the 52 inch hands
clippers lead by seven mavericks with
the ball dancing with george on him
redirect got a hand on it did kawhi
leonard force a turnover
leonard all the way to the rack he'll
take it down as kawhi
leonard got the steal moves it in
transition patrick beverly loving that
nine point lead you know that he is a
one man
fast break look out dominique
and take over games offensively
lebron what a pass howard could not
convert it was knocked out
look at the backside block here by
leonard
reggie jackson lets it fly
[Music]
leonard with the steal goes at zubats
and lays it up and then with a left hand
perform like a first team old defensive
player this year
jumps a passing lane easy opportunity in
transition
just hovering like that defensive back
jokic good stunt there by marcus morris
shot clock at nine murray takes it and
tried to jam it was rejected at the rim
it was
almost saved by beverly kawhi leonard is
doing it all what a defensive play well
jamal murray was trying to
catch a body here look at this oh my
goodness
[Music]
doc rivers has a timeout remaining
celtics do not
smart will inbound walker
shot blocked hawaii leonard blocks it
and the clippers hang on and win in ot
giving up position right there but again
come on
kawhi leonard with that those high hands
high arms covers ground
i mean just the unbelievable defensive
play
to close out what was a beautiful
basketball game
what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report